now before we leave off this training
space how would we work out the volume
of this shape like how much space it
takes up in three dimensions and the
answer is like well actually doesn't
want to suggest okay very good so let's
start in case you didn't catch that have
a look at the shape again you still see
it there when that take off one of the
cross-sections how good's your eyesight
how many units square units does is take
up four plus three plus two plus one
looks like I think it's ten all right
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
okay ten right so in this example right
example okay the volume is going to be
the cross-section I'll put the numbers
in a second the cross-section and its
area and we're going to multiply it by
now look how many cross-sections do I
have and the answer is I have I have
five right like if my Gator was
centimeters okay suppose this was five
centimeters across
okay so it's like well how many
cross-sections how far does this
cross-section get repeated four and in
this particular case it's gonna be fine
right now all we do is record this the
cross-section we call that other thing
the perpendicular height now you guys
have met these before these two words I
wonder if you can see why this is what
we call it because when I say to you
when I give you back this shape what's
happen to get this one for example if I
just said to you what is the height of
this shape what would you say I would
probably say for like that's how high it
is right but do you remember when we
were having a look at the area of a
triangle okay if I told you you've got
the base over here right the height
isn't always up and down
it isn't always that length right where
would the height be in this particular
example someone else someone hasn't said
something yet yeah Rachel
how did if I yeah okay so I can see fine
for example if I give me some names
right you can see it's gonna be from
that point eight right down to be city
and importantly it's gonna be
perpendicular so perpendicular height
and you remember it's because it makes
that little H that's how you know that's
the right height okay now this height
that we're talking that goes along here
it's not up and down it's not up and
down but it's at right angles it's
perpendicular to where the cross
sections are you see that so it's
actually that high and that's why we
said five we all said this five of them
so the cross section times the
perpendicular height now you counted for
me 10 right 10 that's an area right this
is actually the cross section area so
what unit like this just supposed to do
this enemies what unit would I actually
use for this cross sections area yeah
send me a squint very good it's an area
right and then you have a height the
height is kind of like a it's a
one-dimensional thing right so that
would just be
yeah very good so I've got just
centimeters all the time okay so when I
put them together first thing we can do
the numbers 10 times 5 of course is 25
10 times 5 is 15 I've got centimeters
times centimeters times centimeters I
just - centimeters boys listen up all
right so we have a volume here okay now
let's have a look at a couple of other
examples so we can see we don't need to
calculate using just watch you see them
okay now this is a weird shape he's a
weird shape we don't really have a name
for here we go let me pull it off oh
okay this is my cross-section okay what
is it it's like yeah it's like a weird
Tetris piece okay yeah he's my point
though right
even though we don't have a name is it
yeah he's really it's got 12 sides one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven that makes it actually I
think that cuz it makes an undec agon
which is a weird name you never know but
anyway okay now um very close very close
now this shape even though it's so we we
don't even necessarily have to name it
okay I can still work out its area you
can count it out how many how many
squares looks like seven after me right
and what would the height of this shape
be don't forget it needs to be
perpendicular perpendicular to the
cross-section I count one two three four
five six of them counting is hard I get
it it's far away okay so in this in this
case in that case right I'm you have to
write this one down could some weird
example our volume would be what's the
cross-section area
what did we count you can look at it
it's going to be seven centimeters
squared because it's an area across this
area and what was its height it was six
right so therefore it would be 42 cubic
centimeter we have this rectangular
prism let's write down rectangular prism
because we've already worked out this
other volume here so this is the second
the rectangular prism when we work out
the volume we gotta do it this same way
of working out the cross-section it's
area and then we're going to multiply
bikes open to do it now by the way
because as you can see it gets a bit
tiresome this will be the last time we
ride it out in four words gets a bit
tiresome writing you should rather write
each cross section again yeah yeah sure
and on perpendicular high it takes so
long to say those because this cross
section is an area we tend to say just
aim for area right we'll use this
abbreviation in a second instead of
perpendicular height we just write H
behind okay so I'll use that from my
next step which you'll see in a second
have a look at the shape I'll hold it up
for you again right what is the area of
the cross section it's just six deuce
it's a nice easy small number to work
with six centimeters square please don't
miss the units and units are huge deal
listening okay now we want to multiply
it by the perpendicular height which as
you can see is kind of like saying how
many cross sections do I have and the
answer is I have yep four of them yeah
yeah very good okay so in exactly the
same way that I do a normal area so for
examples come back this triangle but
they're just true okay that's fine
so for example if this was three and
this was five right this was three in
this is five okay then I can multiply
these units together it'll be half times
base which is five centimeters times
Hyatt's you can multiply any units
together you like you can't add them
multiply add on a different so this is
this is seven a half centimeters squared
because it's a set of enos touch
centimeters which is centimeter squared
now here I have centimeters by
separators by centimeters three of them
which is why I end up with what's the
number six times 4 12 n you're gonna
have well lessor worth like this would
be you know half a centimeter princess
it was really thin right this would be
say half a centimeter you do 60
centimeters squared times half a
centimeter it would be a small thing I
guess okay
all right now here's that wonderfully I
just want to finish with okay and that's
when we're going to use this psalm
abbreviated version this is not the only
way that we could do this remember I
said it's like ah for you train your
prism there's no other way you can chop
this thing up try to chop it a different
way and you just get different sections
so it's no good right but I can chop
this up different ways can't I I could
think of at least two other ways to do
it can someone explain maybe yeah Ethan
oh that yeah okay so I could do it I
could have this as my cross-section
because there when I separate it the
other side will be exactly the same or
one that that's a second way a third way
is I could turn it this way and now I've
got three sections now this is kind of
interesting right
they put this
and I have a look let's do this one more
time we'll do this quicker right we'll
write V equals a H okay have a look now
this is take two right I'll tip rate out
the cross-section
what's its area I count one two three
four five seven eight
right sir it's AIT's that's the number
what are the units it's an area very
good square centimeters okay how that
looks you can see it frozen there on the
screen and I'll hold it up for you again
right this is the way I had it rotated
if this is what I'm choosing as my
cross-section right what's the
perpendicular height yeah
I see three one two three that's
perpendicular to it's at right angles to
my cross-section right so I multiply
this by three centimeters okay eight
times three it's still 24 and the units
are still centimeters huge okay which
you'd expect because they are the same
shape just divided up twice if we did it
the way Ethan suggested you'd have 12
across the front
how many cross-sections do you have two
of them and twelve times two still 24
same shape